[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
passe toute l'actualité en débat avec
jean baptiste nucléaire que jour maître
de conférences à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
stéphane manceau professeur dans cette
même université vous êtes tous les deux
des publicistes comme on dit oui oui oui
il ne veut pas dire que vous faites de
la publicité
pas du tout mais on pourrait pas ce que
l'oubli site ça veut dire d'autre
mais voilà nous ont félicités pour notre
discipline je le sens de l'avenue
bonjour je mens l'éditeur des émissions
doivent absolument gallimard territoire
des éditions gallimard grasset des
hommes n'existe presque plus au ban de
l'immigration gallimard oui bien
monsieur grâce est encore annoncé et il
ya toujours un enfant vivant je voulais
dire d'accord voilà et florence mercadé
du barreau de versailles avocate du
barreau ses avocates
alors on a beaucoup de soutien et de oui
absolument
non on va parler d'écriture inclusive de
la grammaire inclusive
on apprendra peut-être tout à l'heure ce
qu'il faut utiliser des mots ou est-ce
qu'il faut ajouter ait eu ce que veut
dire une hauteur eu une professeure re
avocate
tout le monde le ni oui ça gêne personne
et j strates et pourquoi ça jamais un
président antoine le dit non il ya plein
de alors madame la présidente et avec le
10 mai c'est la femme du président
annonce le prêt présidente
non mais pas nous donner quand on arrive
en chambre correctionnelle en chambre
sociale c'est une femme qui préside
c'est madame la présidente qui est elle
même présidente et vous dites madame la
professeure à l'université si celle ci
le souhaitent oui mais certains de nos
collègues se font appeler madame le
professeur
oui et on va peut-être commencer par ce
débat finalement puisque on y est on est
dessus alors les critiques visent il ya
ça a été ça a été relancée parce qu'il
ya un manuel qui publie chez hatier qui
mais c'était inclusive pour les pour les
élèves
l'écriture cursive 7 consiste à donner
le masculin et le féminin de chaque de
2,2 par exemple les étudiants et les
étudiantes eux et si on n'écrit pas en
entier étudiants et étudiantes heures ou
mai petite parenthèse ou attirer avec es
non non pas du tout comment non mais pas
du tout c'est bien plus complexe et bien
plus ridicule que ça c'est pas du tout
une parenthèse les crétins qui ont
imaginé ça christine et les crédits les
crétins eux qui reste va c'est pas des
tirs et ils ont inventé le point du
milieu oui à la mena mais ces termes le
ils ont poussé la halle la stupidité
jusqu'à demander aux fabricants
d'ordinateurs qui est dans les
prochaines
machine sur les sur les claviers une
touche avec le point du milieu la bêtise
est sans limites et je sais que vous
alliez parler des 314 non dans des
scandales de 300 enseignants qui aura
sorti en saignant 114 il faut les mettre
en prison et les énormes et cela dans un
manifeste dans lequel ils interdisent
avoir cessé ou s'apprêter à cesser
d'enseigner la règle est amer résumer en
une petite formule connu tout un chacun
le masculin l'emportent sur le féminin
il n'y a pas de raison et c'est vrai que
il ya eu une époque par exemple où il y
avait la règle de la proximité
c'est alors au lieu de dire les jeunes
gens et de jeunes filles sont prêts si
le mot jeune fille était plus proche du
dudu du verbe posé des jeunes gens et de
jeunes filles sont prêtes
c'est après tout je les conneries on a
connu ça je compte mes enfants ont eu un
moment de vie dans leur scolarité
ah oui cette règle de proximité enfin je
ne sais pas c'est pas nouveau
quand on voit l'état de déliquescence de
l'orthographe de l'expression des gens
en ce moment et est d'aider des lycéens
et des étudiants
c'est une canne muscles puis sûr que si
vous êtes heures au niveau de la
compréhension fin de l'écriture d'un
texte
c'est ça va être chaud au delà du au
delà du ridicule et et puis
intellectuellement c'est grotesque et en
plus esthétiquement save est ridicule
dans un livre dans un texte avec ce
point se tirait fins ce s es le tfh tu
sais ça n'a aucun sens c'est vraiment et
puis dollar une vingtaine qui est une
enseignante qui est une chercheuse qui
nous professeurs a professé re à
l'université de paris ii d'une aiguille
enfin une spéciale de l'histoire de la
littérature dit que cette prééminence du
masculin sur le féminin c'est une règle
c'est les rots
mais c'était la scélérate
rien aucune ambiguïté là dessus je crois
en quoi cette règle est à remettre en
cause mais il ya quand même il ya quand
même une domination pour pourquoi dans
les mots y aurait une domination du
masculin sur le féminin est ce que ça
vous gêne vraiment qu'on dise une
grenouille voudriez qu'on dise un
grenouille paraît pas un bébé d'une
esclave et du femina sacem alors asa ben
quoi c'est pas un hasard on dit bien une
sentinelle
on imagine alors ce sont toujours des
hommes une recrue sage femme une
sage-femme ont dépensé je ne saurais
dire non parce que c'est parce que femme
ça ne vient pas de femmes féminin savez
de femmes femmes à la renault bienvenue
mais oui voilà on va faire un cours de
linguistique la réforme de l'armée
française c'est quand même une idéologie
particulière qui se glisse derrière ça
parce qu'il ya un glissement avec cette
idée le masculin l'emporté sur le
féminin qui laissera entendre qu'il ya
une domination masculine sur les femmes
et c'est cette c'est ce glissement qui
est un petit peu trompeur alors est-ce
qu'il faut lutter contre les inégalités
hommes femmes par une transformation la
langue française
je pense qu'il ya d'autres moyens quand
même d'y parvenir c'est à dire il ya en
effet deux états il ya ceux qui disent
notamment bentolila que 8 et 10 mais
c'est un hasard complet paniandy la
table et le plafond mais ça veut pas
dire capables et féminine et que plafond
c'est une forme de neutre et et peu
importe au fond le jean qui est accordé
et puis il y a
plus tôt les féministes on va dire avec
notamment me viénot qui disent non mais
c'est une s'était imposé au 19e siècle
cette règle de la suprématie et c'est
vrai que dans l'accord on accorde avec
le masculin est pas avec pour le coup il
n'y a pas vraiment raison mais même si
des jeunes filles sont plus nombreuses
on accorde avec les jeunes gens est bon
il ya quand même il ya quand même une
bonne part de domination masculine
c'est vrai que ce que moi ce qu'on
m'avait enseigné mais elle n'est pas que
que les moins de vingt ans ne peuvent
pas connaître
c'est que ce masculin est l équivalent
du neutre puisque notre langue ne va pas
neutre n'y a pas de neutre dans les
chronos alors que dans d'autres langues
il ya des actrices oui le l'espagnol le
turc tpao l'anglais ou non voilà donc le
masculin est pris pour faire fonction de
neutrons
alors soyons soyons précis mais c'est
vrai enfin je suis honoré de jean
baptiste vient comme ça qu'on entend
dans ce grand priorité mais alors c'est
très intéressant parce que
les débats sur la langue française en
france sont des débats vous avez une
idéologie passionné je sais plus qui
racontait enfin c'était en
je crois cependant le contenu l'est le
11 septembre 2001
sylvain journal anglais finissais ma
langue et enfin tout le monde ne parle
que de ça mais en france on s'étripe ce
qui aurait une réforme de l'orthographe
vous êtes dit fication d'orthographe
c'est vrai que est par exemple la
simplification d'orthographe dont on
parle depuis longtemps
est-ce que c'est très gênant c'est très
gênant oui c'est très gênant parce que
c'est l'orthographe c'est quand même un
minimum de règles qui permet la
compréhension des textes
donc c'est quand même un principe
fondateur donc après on peut toujours
dire n'importe quoi et dire on s'en fout
les ont faites fabriquons des centaines
d'illettrés on les parque rats on en
fera des tvo absolue et ils n'ont pas
besoin de savoir lire
même plus besoin de savoir écrire on
leur donne un clavier avec quatre
touchés puis ils diront oui ou non mais
mais ces sept c'est ça l'idée mais mais
mais oui on peut toujours écrire en
phonie les naissains et oui mais mes
opinions des mots comme ça on peut dire
n'importe quoi
c'était on peut tout détruire bien
évidemment c'est le connaissez des
règles alors là pour le coup c'est
d'accord
on peut être d'accord et vous mais je
veux dire le le point les lélés les
accents circonflexes etc
c'est arrivé au xvième siècle parce que
les imprimeurs les ont mis sur leur
machine mais ça n'existait pas avant
c'est une complication qui ne qui n'a
pas de racines grammaticales s'ils
viennent dans la sinistre xl c'est un
truc de l'imprimeur mais il ya trois
minutes vous le disais qu'au 16e siècle
le masculin ne l'emporté pas sur le
féminin et c'était très bien et il a
maintenu au xvième siècle c'est les
imprimeurs qui rajoute des accents et là
c'est bien
enfin la spalinger par exemple evènement
ces événements prend deux axes en
l'ayant déjà sans légumes on peut les
mettre jeu suivant des dictionnaires à
l'avenant l'année mais si je me souviens
bien pourquoi ça prend deux sens aigü
c'est parce que les saintes tripper de
de linux ionnaires n'avait pas d'accent
grave on peut l'écrire
non bon alors évidemment on peut dire
c'est comme ça tu sais bien changé mais
la raison pour laquelle c'est comme ça
elle est quand même faible
oui mais l'usagé est important c'est
vrai que je me demande si c'est vraiment
une question pourquoi c'est comme ça
mais en attendant c'est comme ça et en
attendant on s'arrête au rouge et on
passe au vert alors on peut décider
qu'on puisse s'arrêter au vert est passé
au rouge
mais sauf que je crois que l'orthographe
c'est aussi un à la fois c'est un code
et puis c'est un vecteur de relations de
relations interpersonnelles de relations
sociales et ça va au delà de la
possibilité de se comprendre
c'est l'un des fondements de ce que de
ce qui fait qu'une société
et constitu ait ou pas ce sera après
exactement comme il en naît de
l'élocution de sa façon de parler du
vocabulaire qu'on emploie dire que on
est en train de recréer de deux classes
il ya des gens qui maîtriseront
l'orthographe qui maîtriseront un
certain savoir une façon de s'exprimer
et puis et puis il ya la plèbe là qu'on
aura méprisés en dix ans dans écrivait
nénuphars avec un f ou même métier dans
3 c'est pas grave c'est joli si vous
trouvez ça présent ne vous gênait pas
c'est vrai on est ouvert et cetera
et puis dit une des du phare parce que
pourquoi le nénuphar serait ou masculin
effectivement se demande pourquoi donc
on aura tous toute cette population
qu'on aura à betty et et puis qui
s'exprimera avec trois ou quatre mots de
vocabulaire et et deux ou trois
graphiques différentes pour chaque terme
et toute façon voilà ça suffirait les
différenciations sociales ou culturelles
[Musique]
électro au contraire on va aller creuser
parce que je ne peux pas croire un seul
instant que dans les très bons lycées et
dans les très bonnes familles dans les
très bons milieux
les parents ont dit à leurs enfants mais
tu as raison à temps on s'en fou écrit
oignons comme tu veux écrits des dû
faire avec trauner il voulait supprimer
le nom à une réforme possible enfin
c'est une symbolique aux enseignants
c'est prendre les gens pour des crétins
télé en dérision les gens ne sont pas
suffisamment intelligent pour apprendre
une règle
la façon dont vous allez aussi un
peut-être aussi importante que la façon
dont les cris il peut peut-être même
présidé à la façon dont on l'écrit mais
oui mais renonce ont la langue française
et parfois j'aimerais c'est ce que ça me
changeait l'enfant mais je dis si la
langue française est trop compliqué
parce que c'est pas justement un
mouvement perpétuel de modification de
changement est pas figé et pourquoi pas
ouvrir ce que c'est ouvrir la langue
française décrit rognon comme ça se
prononce kouif et aux compagnies pour
décrire de bruit de brebis à les avoir
en tout cas d'être pas d'accord nous
sommes français paupineau il faut
toujours cités françaises popineau qui
dit la langue n'est pas pour rien dans
ce sexisme un peu sourd véhiculées dans
notre société et l'école avec d'autres
institutions
si tu nous regardes on ne brasse pas
enfin moi je t'embrasse est présent
cette idéologie dangereuse quand même
parce que quand on dit les hommes
naissent et demeurent libres et égaux en
droits ça peut laisser entendre
oui mais que que j'exclus les femmes
dans l'avenir dont je vais penser cette
phrase et on sait bien qu'il n'est
absolument pas le cas et c'est là que
c'est dangereux parce qu'on se fait
taper sur les doigts alors que on nous
reprochons quelque chose comme est ce
que ce serait
les hommes et les femmes libres et
égales
non mais on s'en sort plus et puis comme
homme ça veut dire qui vient de la terre
donc de ce point de vue là les femmes
sont des droits de l'homme mères des
enfants les droits de l'homme et de la
femme et cherche des enfants encore une
fois je constate une grande proximité
intellectuelle entre jean charles lajoie
denis et jean michel blanquer
un nid de l'éducation nationale qui a
dit on ne peut pas instrumentaliser la
langue au nom d'une cause aussi noble
soit elle ce n'est pas rendre service
aux élèves que de ne pas leur enseigner
cette langue telle qu'elle est pratiquée
de telles que le programme des
terminales publicis acquis par là et
c'est parler alors la semaine dans les
universités par cette affaire de droit
public colère des professeurs et
professeures et professeurs eux explique
que pour enseigner la langue française
sur des tout-petits maternelle et début
de primaire avec cette inclusion été
extrêmement compliqué mais c'est vrai
saut tandis qu'ici si je dit colette et
d'une des plus grande écrivaine
française de la langue française et
compass et 10 et peut-être plus
restreinte 6 10 et une des plus grands
écrivains
absolument seulement nous sommes
d'accord que
avec pivot des bulls a totalement
scandaleux que 314 enseignants puissent
se mettre hors la loi et ne pas
respecter les programmes que j'avais
décidé que c'était une rébellion à la
catalane s'est prise au jeu
non mais le mot est faible en charge
vous êtes vous êtes trop dans la nuance
mais je pense que c'est ça risque aussi
d'être dommageable pour leurs élèves
surtout bien sûr elle différente par
rapport à celle qu'on enseigne aux
autres mais un professeur donc peut
s'affranchir du programme voir une
professeur e al je ne sais pas enfin
pour ce qui nous concerne les curieux
calibre des programmes mais pas en ce
sens là en tout cas mais moi je voulais
signaler quand même sur la féminisation
des titres ou des qualités gg j'ai passé
dans ma prime jeunesse une année à
étudier au québec et c'est là que j'ai
découvert les auteurs eux les
professeurs eux c'est là aussi que j'ai
découvert que les professeurs n'appelait
pas mais mais mais mais mais mes
camarades étudiante mademoiselle mais
les appeler madame ce que nous faisons
maintenant à titre administratif et moi
je fais je le fais depuis assez
longtemps et et j'avoue que ça ce qui
m'a marqué dans la société québécoise
s'est en effet quelques si j'ose dire
oui quelques années d' avance sur sur la
lutte contre le sexisme culturel le
sexisme ordinaire alors la société
québécoise vittel mieux que la société
française je n'en sais rien mais de ce
point de vue là en tout cas elle me
semble assez assez en pointe
d'une manière assez efficace
la position des femmes dans la société
québécoise est assez assez différente de
ce qu'elle peut être encore chez nous et
en effet avec avec une une société qui
vous le savez évidemment est extrêmement
attaché à la langue française vous
circuler en véhicule terrestre à moteur
dans les rues de montréal il n'est pas
de panneau stop puisque stocha vous
heurter à des panneaux arrêt enfin il ya
les bons toutous donc voilà ce rapport
aussi entre la langue et la situation
d'un groupe social dans la société elle
est quand même aussi importante de la
donc vous de modérer les propos est sûre
sur la féminisation de titres etc
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelques années quand on disait madame
la ministre le ministre aujourd'hui
sachant qu'une personne dise madame la
ministre
mais cela dit c'est vrai vous parliez
tout à l'heure de tous les deux mais
l'ambassadrice c'est quand même les
pousses de l'ambassadeur un ambassadeur
féminin vous lui dites madame
l'ambassadeur est pas la crise mais ça
c'est encore vrai qu'en vrai mais c'est
vrai oui parce que bah quoi que
l'ambassadrice a là un vrai rôle à jouer
aussi
en général oui mais l'ambassadrice pour
être attendre un problème c'est que je
veux c'est la femme qui est vrai je ne
sais pas comment on appelle les baril
l'époux de mme adam lang marine madame
l'ambassadrice monsieur bazin en tout
cas m'hamdi et nous voilà on a demandé
cet été le chef d'orchestre avait
répondu oui surtout si vous écrivez chef
ch e 2 et feu c'est du lourd donc
alors beaucoup de sujets évidemment
cette semaine alors il ya nicolas hulot
qui est au centre des débats puisque il
a renvoyé un peu la transition de l'uqtr
à hama plus tard en puisque la loi
prévoit y est là la fin enfin 50% de
nucléaire en 2005 25 et on s'est rendu
compte que si on voit là si on tenait
ces délais on était obligé de faire plus
de pollution puisqu'il faudrait remettre
à des fins de charbon etc d'autre
énergie puisque des énergies des herses
non polluants ne sont pas encore tout à
fait au point
alors ça peut toujours pose le problème
de nicolas hulot est ce que il a raison
d'être au gouvernement parce que c'est
toujours difficile pour un point
quelqu'un qui représente une course
comme ça et qui est qu une popularité
très fort d'ailleurs dans cette cause
d'être obligé de se confronter à la
réalité il le fait plus éthique de la
ligue 2 l'as de la conviction ticket là
dessus et a été assez assez logique
aussi bien sur le gui phosphate où il
mène un combat c'est assez efficace et
là sur les centrales nucléaires il a
faim il a totalement raison à savoir si
on veut polluez pas polluer je veux dire
il n'y a pour l'instant pas d'autre
solution que de conserver cette part du
nucléaire dans notre approvisionnement
énergétique de la cc c'est juste du bon
sens et de l'intelligence ya pas de ya
même pas de débat qu'après et des écolos
ça toujours en train de râler c'est un
peu leur rôle mais mais lui il a la
responsabilité de
du gouvernemental et ce qu'il dit
intelligent absolument incontestable
on va se passer des saveurs de gens qui
dit aux fouilles trahi la cause
c'est un militant qui est raisonnable
qui efface au fait qui doit assumer le
fait que c'est parra c'est pas possible
gaëtan aux responsabilités il peut pas
venir dire quoi qu'il arrive on va faire
2025 il réaliste voire aux
responsabilités pour connaître la
faisabilité des objectifs qui ont été
affichés donc en arrivant au
gouvernement il s'est rendu compte que
cela jamais d'ailleurs été très
idéologique actuel est plus pragmatique
idéologiquement il l'avait déjà dit au
moment du vote de la loi mais il
faudrait voir comment comment ça se
passe dans la réalité si je restais
purement idéologique et dogmatique il
faudrait qu'ils pourraient pas rester sa
session je crois au contraire que c'est
une preuve de courage que de s'inscrire
dans le réel
et puis ça dénote aussi le pinceau
ségolène royal qui a été aux
responsabilités deux ans plus tôt n'a
finalement pas ne s'est pas donné les
moyens d'atteindre les objectifs qui
avaient été fixés
je crois que vos traitements l'aider
ça donne une certaine noblesse justement
au courant écologiste parce que c'est
bien con plus que nicolas hulot qui est
un écolo soit responsable et pas un doux
rêveur ou un type uniquement dans
l'opposition tout en train de râler en
train de faire ceci voudrait faire cela
non la ccc juste claire et nette
on peut pas on peut pas donc on décale
et puis c'est tout il expliqué et c'est
d'autant plus le message écologiste est
d'autant plus crédible qu'il est
réaliste moi je je je je trouve qu'il y
a eu pendant assez longtemps une
arrogance insupportable de la part de
certains écologistes je pense à eux
mêmes du show par exemple etc
enfin c'est pas la seule mais yahia
jadot jadu nous je ne place plus tôt et
3 me les écologistes crédible crédible
mais c'est toujours ça
ce vieux débat entre l'éthique de la
conviction l'éthique de la
responsabilité c est ce qu on va au bout
de 2
ce qu'on croit et quitte à être
réalistes ou est ce que quand on est
ministre on a on devoir responsabilités
qui vous engage à chacun dans son rôle
les écolos qui sont à l'extérieur du
gouvernement revendique et l'écolo qui
est au gouvernement liger et ely d'ely
responsable il fait il fait le job est
plutôt bien l'allemagne l'a fait
l'allemagne est l'un des deux principaux
pollueurs européens sinon le plus est ce
que le donc la question c'est est-ce que
le nucléaire est laminée écologistes
l'ami de l'environnement même court
terme agresseurs terme donc et pas de
débat non mais sachant plus le bleu le
temps que le tonneau mais il va rester
c'est au fond juste
est ce qu'il ya un moment où quand on
est nicolas hulot avec ce qu'ils
représentent
est ce qu'il ya un moment où on peut
plus justement rester dans un
gouvernement qui tourne le dos à
certains objectifs écologiques on sait
très bien
edouard philippe le dit d'ailleurs très
bien que nous pas il n'a pas une
sensibilité écologique très très forte
je pense pas qu emmanuel macron ça soit
sa première sensibilité non plus non
mais il n'a pas non plus de renoncement
forte que ce que je connais pas de
renoncements énorme du gouvernement et
de manuel da cruz david e
de l'écologie jeudi paraît pas être
gouvernés par des gens qui se foutent de
la planète ni de la terre n'est de l'air
qu'on respire au contraire ils prennent
les choses les unes après les autres
moments il faut les aborder
ils sont responsables et plutôt
intelligent là dessus donc il faut
arrêter de penser que quelqu'un que tout
peut se régler d'un coup de baguette
magique de demain on peut lui rappeler
on roulera plus on fera un fois plus
dense et les choses sont quand même
beaucoup plus compliqué est ce pour ça
je veux pas beaucoup de raisons que l'os
en a et il est très bien il est ministre
d'état il fait bien le boulot je
démissionne à peine nommé ou donnés
partants oui c'est aussi parce que je
pense que tous les hommes politiques et
tous les précédents premiers ministres
et présidents sont furieux parce qu'ils
ont tous essayé d'enrôler hulot ils ont
tous qui réussissent et mâcon ils sont
ils sont ivres de rage parce qu'il dit
bah ouais nous on aurait bien aimé bah
oui mais ma croix suis trouvé des
arguments que visiblement il n'avait pas
et d'une façon générale qui se pensaient
de la justement d'aider on pourrait dire
qu'il fait un peu partie de la société
civile
lou nicolas hulot et les ministres
enfants qui viennent de la société
civile ici ne pas se débrouiller seul
après faudrait faire le tri entre les
uns et les autres puisqu'il va y avoir
un remaniement bientôt avec le départ de
questionnaires à la tête de en marche
finalement les ministres qui viennent de
la société civile sont pas ceux qui se
débrouillent le plus mal semble-t-il je
moi j'ai toujours du mal à savoir ce que
c'est que société civile afin qu'ils
n'étaient pas des professionnels oui on
peut le dire oui mais ça je sais rien
des critiques sur le mix de l'intérieur
et les crêperies charles vi de les
affaires étrangères ils sont des
démissions de deux points il ya le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
priori comme ça on s'en foutent
le 20 10 2 du travail
le garde des sceaux qui te sont
progressistes
voilà mettez des publics partout même là
où ils ne connaissent rien
encore que le ministre de la santé
médecins et la milice de l'armée d'une
culture a eu le prix beaucoup plus bas
nous non plus il ya un truc je pense
qu'à pas de truc sinon c'est une insulte
voilà je suis d'avis
le prix goncourt mais et puis quelques
autres prix mais c'est une très très
bonne maison d'édition donc n'y a pas de
c'est pas plus truqués cette année que
ça n'aurait pu l'être annonce mais est
ce que je dis - enfin voila c est ce que
vous pensez quand on est assuré par
exemple goncourt c'est une question
qu'on se pose est-ce que ça serait plus
ça va peut être un argument contre le
livre qui a été primé oui ces quelques
mauvais esprits ce disque elle servit
attention
oui mais il ya aussi les gens qui
parcourent pas rien ne vient pas c'est
vrai qu'après ou dernier tour entre deux
ont dit ben y en a chez actes sud et
piloter qui est pas chez actes sud
pourquoi pas si on me donnait actes sud
donc on peut penser d2 après non ça
reste des bouquins pas très passionnant
sur le thème qu'ils abordent enfin c'est
un peu inquiétant que le des écrivains
ce que plus du nazisme et de l'histoire
que poser une question qui regarde si on
regarde au fond les des prix littéraires
on a l'impression que le roman évolue de
plus en plus vers la biographie et
l'histoire plutôt que vers l'invention
et la faim ou de la fiction proprement
dit
le renaudot comme le goncourt récompense
de deux livres qui sur les fringues et
le l'autre sur la montée du nazisme qui
sont presque des livres d'histoire et
géographie
c'est surtout l'impression que les
auteurs se refusent d'aborder des thèmes
quasiment d'actualité on sait bien que
romancier s'est pas non plus faire de
journaliser nadal et le prix femina et
d'un très bon livre aussi sont un crime
qui a lieu en 42
crimes réels avec un naturel qui ensuite
a été un parent est totalement
déconnectée de la réalité de la société
actuelle et c'est donc ça veut dire quoi
ça curieux de s'intéresser que ce qui
s'est passé
l'époque du nazi fin de prix goncourt
qui nous raconte comment les les
industriels allemands ont joué la carte
de l'unité
ledit clair dès le départ enfin quelle
nouvelle enfin c'est comme si on ne
savait pas à fabriquer qu'est ce qu'on
apprend l'afp n'ont laissé que juste le
nier c'est plus l'objet de ça pour être
plus d'offrir des livres d'histoire oui
l'histoire celle des romanciers nous
parle d'amour jean-charles en résumé
enfin ils peuvent y est il a tout à fait
le plein de sujets car ici regardez
aurélien par exemple d'aragon ça peut
parler on peut parler d'amour et et de
oui-oui et de l'après guerre les grands
romans histoire d'amour des capitaines
d'industrie de l'allemagne de 1933
non mais c'est ses bassines déry enfin
cette tendance est en tout cas c'est
intéressant je préférais que le prix
goncourt qui s'intéressent un peu ce qui
s'est passé c'est pas nous soyons
septembre au bataclan enfin crevé
raconte qu'on sache un petit peu ce que
tous ces gens peuvent penser imaginer de
la société actuelle n'a pas du tout non
les à berlin en 33 très bien pour paris
paris 2002 15 on attendra un siècle pour
qu'on nous en parle et se séparent sur
les jeux olympiques ça curieux et ben
justement puisque vous parlez du
bataclan on peut aborder la question du
verdict et du procès d'abdelkader meira
donc
défendu par maître dupond-moretti grand
pénaliste quand avocat d'assises offense
votre contrôle donc un tel cas vers mehr
a été condamné mais acquitté du chef
principal de l'accusation qui était
suite complicité avec son frère qu'est
ce que alors je pense que les juristes
sont à peu près d'accord avec une
décision comme celle-là même si
l'opinion peut la comprendre difficile
sa requête de sujets le sujet des
juristes et l'application stricte de la
loi et en l'espèce la complicité la
notion de complicité au sens pénal ne
tenez absolument pas qu'il n'y avait pas
de faits de complicité de la part de
mera à l'égard de son frère
c'est quoi des faits commis ses défauts
ainsi si besoin est réel
non seulement il faut une participation
active à la commission du crime
je vais l'aider à voler un scooter avec
des crimes il faut prouver alors il peut
être complice du vol du scooter mais pas
complice de la tuerie dès lors qu'il
n'avait pas connaissance il n'est pas
rapporté la preuve de la connaissance de
ce que ce scooter va servir à
l'accomplissement de ce crime dont il ya
pas de participation active comme un
complice et il n'y a pas d'intention et
le fait d'avoir des paroles enfin d
ça c'est autre chose on verra non mais
les paroles ce qu'ils disaient c'était
autre chose
ils n'étaient pas en train sur la
complicité s'il avait dit dans ses
paroles on a volé ce scooter et c'était
pour tuer des gens sans nommer telle ou
telle personne à tel ou tel endroit
mais c'est pas ça qui l'a dit celui-là
tout le temps dit autre ère du procès
qu'il refusait les règles de notre
démocratie les règles républicaines et
qu' il était validé des arguments très
très radicaliser qu'il revendiquait mais
pour après on est sur un autre débat qui
peut être un débat moral l'enjeu petit
débat entre vous et j'ai alors là on est
encore dans le droit sur la notion de
complicité puis après on abordera
peut-être le savoir est ce que ce
droit-là doit s'appliquer ouvrage juste
raté le départ il était poursuivi
uniquement sur la complicité et
postérieurement mois elle a été la
société la salle
il a été condamné ce qu'ils savaient que
en laissant uniquement la complicité qui
a des problèmes de dresde
alors l'association de malfaiteurs dont
dupont brésil déguisé disent que c'est
un four tops absolument t il c'est un
fourre tout jean baptiste est justement
parce qu'en matière juridique il faut
distinguer entre les textes entre les
faits et il ya aussi la qualification
juridique des faits ni alors sur les
textes effectivement une distinction
entre associations malfaiteurs et
complicité d'assassinât qui pour
schématiser veut que dans le premier cas
d une sorte d' adhésion
sur donc l'entreprise terroriste qui
était conduit par mohamed merah ça c'est
sûr ça c'est plutôt dense et noël c'est
l'association de malfaiteurs alors que
sur la complicité d'assassinât il faut
qu'on aille un petit peu plus loin mais
la différence est quand même ténue il
faut qu'il y ait un acte positif qui
puisse être un acte matériel ou un acte
immatériel donc toute la question est
ensuite sur la qualification juridique
des faits à partir du moment où abdel
kader meira a participé au vol du
scooter t max est ce qu'on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ya là un acte matériel
positif alors il faudrait encore il est
vrai pouvoir démontrer que il la danse
est un temps faim ils savaient qu'en
volant ce scooter celui ci allait être
utilisée pour commettre l'attentât
terroriste mais enfin on peut quand même
en discuter et puis ça peut être aussi
une dimension immatérielle il faut qu'il
y est je crois un homme qui était donné
une emprise exercée sur sur le frère une
intentionnelle donc c'est vrai qu'on
peut piocher dans des éléments de la
delà du premier chan a réculé passion
qui est le sésame l'association de
malfaiteurs pour dire qu'effectivement à
partir du moment où une cautionne
exactement été commis par son frère
est-ce que ça n'enrichit pas donc est ce
que la distinction juridique n'est elle
même pas un petit peu survécu ambiguë
donc il est vrai que le débat n'est pas
aussi simple mais fort que l'autre qui
étaient dans le box malki avait quand
même fourbit les armes et n'a pas été
condamnée non plus pour complicité alors
qu'il avait fourni des armées disaient
mais moi si j'avais su que ces armes
allaient servir à tuer des gens dans ces
conditions là jamais je n'aurais vendu
les armes
en train entre souvenirs à se voler un
scooter et fournir des armes
il était moins combelles ils étaient
combien 14 ans oui mais oui il année à
14 ans mais dans l'esprit dans l'esprit
fournir des armes on se dit pourquoi pas
un mot juridique avant de vous laisser
la parole en cour d'assises
c'est de l'intimé conviction et même
quand ils ce sont des magistrats
professionnels
donc on n'a même pas besoin de modifier
de motiver de motiver des s'il allait
même s'ils devraient condamné pour
complicité
là ce qui s'est passé c'est pour ça
qu'on a attendu longtemps le jugement
entre le moment où la cour a commencé à
lire son arrêt ils ont extrêmement
motivé oui pour pour le bloc fait pour
nous pour que les gens puissent
comprendre pourquoi il soit une telle
qu'on la messe ils ont absolument
mais il est rare qu'il y ait des
motivations de cet ordre là c'est parce
que c'est des magistrats professionnels
a mérité une cour d'assises spéciale
on peut penser que si j'avais été une
cour d'assises avec d'un jury populaire
le jeu le réseau aurait peut-être pas
épais mais je pense que les magistrats
professionnels qui font partie de la
cour d'assises aurait quand même motivé
sur sur un cas aussi aussi complexe
effectivement en cours d'assises en juge
avec son intime conviction ce qui lui
est ce que on n'est pas obligé problème
allemand n'est pas obligé de s'expliquer
et là ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait ils
ont bien fait de le faire
bardon non non non je vais venir un mort
rapide sur la distinction entre
associations malfaiteurs et complicité
d'assassinât
même si la nuance est ténue je crois
qu'elle est éminemment importante dans
notre démocratie puisque
alors si on prend pour vrai la décision
qui a été rendue par la cour
je crois qu'il ya énormément d'appels
kader mme meira et un peu moins et c'est
heureux de mohamed merah c'est à dire
qu'il ya je crois dans notre société
beaucoup de gens qui sont d'accord avec
les actes commis par les terroristes
on le voit notamment avec les
publications encore de 2 de charlie
hebdo où on a beaucoup de gens qui sur
les réseaux sociaux disent qu'ils
doivent avoir la mort qu'il souhaite que
les terroristes puissent refaire ce qui
a déjà été fait et donc finalement
beaucoup d'abdel kader meira c'est à
dire qu'ils sont complètement d'accord
et qui souscrivent parfaitement à ce
qu'il fait mais qui ne sont pas
forcément des gens même s'il reçoit
rebasculer qui vont passer à l'acte
qu'ils vont fournir des armes qui vont
aider à la commission d'un acte criminel
mais alors après parce que de manière
plus morale alors moi je suis dit qu'est
ce que justement ces propos favorables
ne ne font pas un creuset qui permet à
des gens de passer à la ccpc pénalement
aussi répréhensible 2002 répondre de
tels propos
non mais appelant retrait à donnée à 20
ans mais en trente ans maintenant 30 ans
c'est normal qu'à bernard et pardon été
condamné à 20 ans oui parce que c'était
le maximum à l'époque maintenant ses 30
ans dans certaines réformes et non mais
moi je suis
ravi de toutes ces explications et je
pense qu'effectivement d'un point de vue
purement juridique il n'y a pas de
critiquer apporte effectivement il ya
sûrement une compréhension très très
compliqué de la part de comme le dit
florence du peuple qui s'étonne un peu
que ce type qui est quand même assez peu
sympathiques soient s'en sort finalement
assez bien
on comprend effectivement assez mal que
le l'autre été condamnés à 14 ans qui
dit oui je tenais une arme je savais pas
la même attitude
non parce qu'il s'est excusé parce qu'il
avait des regrets parce que lui fera pas
prêts pour autant il n'y a pas eu la
même attitude
c'est quand même curieux de donner une
arme à quelqu'un dont on ne sait pas
qu'il allait s'en servir est ce qu'il
pensait vraiment que tu es pour décorer
le mur de la chambre de mes rares voilà
c'est ça ce sont des choses un peu
curieuse après ce qui va être
intéressant ces procès en appel parce
que effectivement est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres
d'autres arguments défendus mais je
pense que effectivement il y aura besoin
de ce procès pour que la question allait
elle est de savoir est-ce que fasse
parler de ce nom de guerre et c est ce
que c'est le même droit qui doit
s'impliquer que le droit qui s'applique
de façon alors vous direz c'est de te
cour d'assises spéciale c'est déjà pas
par là même la même chose mais est ce
que au fond des il n'y a pas le droit de
d'une démocratie ça devient pas le droit
d'un pays faibles par rapport à une
attaque qui était celle de comme une
attaque comme les terroristes
je trouve que la faiblesse ce serait de
temps prendre c'est ce que dit de
pedretti mais que le club ne serait pas
de condamner très fermement
moi je viens certains ça me paraît
toujours ça me paraît toujours un pur
plaisir la science caf blesse et de ne
pas condamner ou 7 des lois
sur la notion de complicité en matière
de terrorisme
le passé au peloton d'exécution série 1
je suis assez d'accord avec nos amis je
touche effectivement c'est bien que le
droit soit appliqué qui ont commencé à
avoir des différentes juridictions
durant sa civic erreurs des différentes
façons de juger dans de la justice ça
serait quand même très inquiétant c'est
le propre de la démocratie c'est quand
même deux qu'on arrive à respecter ça
qu'on arrive à faire abstraction simple
document de l'opinion publique et du
tout ce qu'on veut penser
en revanche notre démocratie
s'honorerait que ce type fasse vraiment
20 ans de prison
et l'on peut espérer voilà alors quand
j'entends la condamnation est non ya 14
ans de peines incompressibles
incompressibles après il peut ali je
compte c'est qu'avant brésil
généralement fait pas 20 ans d'abord et
puis ensuite même toute peine
incompressible peut être révisé ça s'est
vu très souvent en tant que peine
incompressible ce pas dire grand chose
en fait c'est condamner de les peines
incompressibles qui n'ont pas fait la
durée d'euros par exemple des jeux
revient quand même à ce que disait un
peu jean baptiste total à mais quelqu'un
qui est quelqu'un qui prononce des mots
comme comme a prononcé à des caméras est
ce que c'est pas aussi dangereux que de
fournir des armes c'est bien pire
donc est-ce que c'est pas une complicité
très forte
est ce que cette paille c'est pas une
notion non c'est moins dangereux parce
qu'on fait pas toujours ce qu'on dit
alors que les terroristes font ce qu'ils
font sentir puisque justement s'il le
disait il serait appréhendé mais je
crois surtout que sur le débat entre
terrorisme et démocratie il faut quand
même reconnaître que le terrorisme
contribue à diminuer très largement de
droit la liberté et c'est heureux que ce
que ce soit le cas pourquoi parce que la
lutte contre le terrorisme impliquent un
renoncement à certains endroits et nos
libertés et donc à des logiques
préventive en terme de perquisition
administratives qui sont absolument
nécessaires puisque la sur le procès
verra on se trouve finalement sur le
volet répressif mais on se rend bien
compte que finalement une fois que les
choses ont été faites le touriste est
mort en et puis les victimes sont mortes
dont finalement on se on se retourne un
petit peu vers ceux de kader mira mais
je crois que l'enjeu est surtout sur
haut niveau au niveau préventif et c'est
à ce stade là effectivement que nous
revenions sur nos droits et libertés
pour faire qu'on puisse appréhender des
terroristes avant qu'il puisse commettre
l'irréparable
et là je reviens d'un mot à dire
heureusement va y avoir un appel
est ce que c'est bien qu'ils aient un
appel pour ce genre de deux procès une
horreur pour les familles nombreuses en
plus et ça c'est terrible c'est partout
on veut dire dans tous les crimes dans
tous les délits à tout le monde doit
supporter la lenteur de
le problème c'est la lenteur de la
justice avec le délai entre le prononcé
de l'arrêt de la cour d'assises et voilà
il ya déjà cinq ans est la moins deux
ans au moins deux ans puisqu'il ya cent
cinquante 150 dossiers qui sont dans
cette section anti-terroriste avec pas
suffisamment de juge donc disent nous on
peut pas aller plus vite que la musique
par rapport à la masse de dossiers que
l'on a et et alors ce qui est terrible
c'est que tout le monde sait souffle
dans ses procédures et ce qui veut dire
que dans deux ans je pense ou un an et
demi quand ça reviendra on n'aura pas le
même débat il y aura pas le même étalage
journalistique je pense et puis les
familles seront fatigués ce sera pas la
même intensité très difficile mais c'est
très difficile pour tout le monde et à
pour les témoins enfin bon pour
recommencer à zéro je crois que souvent
on voit ça dans les procès en appel avec
nous ça va plus vite ça peut-être pas
durer cinq semaines ça va aller
peut-être plus vite va y avoir moins
d'intensité - de bon mais c'est vrai
pour les victimes c'était séduire le
couteau dans la plaie il fait d'ailleurs
un une proposition qui a été faite par
deux avocats pour aller plus vite en
matière j siens puis si on manque de
magistrats et que les délais sont très
longs c2c de restreindre énormément
alors je ne parle pas que des cours
d'assises mais la possibilité d'appel à
des questions de droit à des questions
d'avoir beaucoup moins d'appels ce qui
est évidemment parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'appels qui quitte la majorité d une
grande majorité des décisions se sont
confirmées en appel
c'est souvent dilatoire c'est souvent
pour gagner du temps c'est souvent pour
des procédures je pense que s'il mettait
l'exécution provisoire c'est l'addiction
largement et que les exécuter des leurs
non c est que l'appel ne sera pas
suspensif et massy déjà il y avait cela
même si ça peut paraître dès fois
injustes quand un jugement qui est de
barrage on peut avoir un jugement aussi
au-delà du fait qu'on puisse se dire que
c'est un mauvais jugement pas voir ici
un jugement parfaitement injuste donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya des sommes
importantes à pas bon jeu en jeu du coup
faire une exécution provisoire mais
peut-être avec un séquestre sur la
caisse des dépôts s'il ya des noms des
choses comme ça peut-être pas forcément
ça moi j'ai eu des dossiers ou mauvais
jugement et on gagne en appel avec des
sommes importantes qui ont été donnés
alors bon moi je fais du droit du
travail donc côté plutôt employeurs avec
des sommes importantes donner aux
salariés où on n'arrive pas à récupérer
les fonds
parce qu'ils ont été dilapidés et que la
personne n'a tout à tout dépenser quoi
il s'est dit sommes des fois importante
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que toi il
faudrait il faudrait oui pour fedreim
post d'après qu'au cas où l'appel comme
l'appelle dans l'autre sens mais aussi
parfois des bon jugement en première
instance et des mauvais jugement en
après l'appel mais metz
mais peut-être que la systématisation de
l'appel n'était qu'un système à 6,2 me
type patrice enfin je viens pour pour ce
que je connais un peu moins mal devant
les juridictions
il avait pourtant 80% des jugements
rendus par les tribunaux administratifs
sont définitives mais y'a des délais oui
c'est bien arrangé c'est toujours
insupportable je suis d'accord avec mr
très vite pour arriver à la décision du
tribunal administratif c'est moins d'un
an maintenant je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de volume le volume et c'est le dis
on appelle on voit mal le frère meira
avoir une peine plus légère
pour l'instant la défense a pas pire
animal qui a fait appel le premier
ensuite le parquet a fait appel et puis
à maera s'appelle voulait dire un mot
départ 10 p pas ou pas quelque chose à
dire à des parades à ces paradis ce pape
et non mais parce qu'enfin le moral et
de morale et de droit on s'aperçoit au
fond que d'optimisation fiscale et les
noms des gens qui ont participé le son
sont parues dans la presse mais au fond
il n'ya pas d'illégalité
ça dépend à quel stade parce qu'on peut
ne pas avoir d'illégalité sur
l'opération qui est découverte à l'île
de man on wire mais après effectivement
tout vient c'est bien l'argent c'est
dans les journaux il faut remonter un
peu plus en amont et ça c'est très très
compliqué au niveau judiciaire je pense
que les juges il faudrait avoir une
juridiction internationale comme l'ail à
un regroupement de journalistes
internationaux internationaux qui
auraient pu mener l'enquêté
il faudrait qu'il y ait une juridiction
internationale avec des juges qui me met
qui mutualisent leurs moyens parce qu'un
pauvre jugent très bien ce qu'on soit
les mêmes un peu partout
oui déjà en europe ce qui est un peu
aberrant c'est que tout ce dont on parle
est absolument légal
oui bah oui avant avons créé doit
changer
enfin bon pour l'instant je dirais rien
d'illégal à à mettre son argent à l'île
de man au pays bas ah ça c'est une autre
question si l'argent est acquis
frauduleusement ça c'est autre chose
mais je dire placer de l'argent dans un
pays d'europe qui a des conventions
fiscales plus avantageux c'est logique
quand quand tous les français vont
mettre de l'argent sur leurs livrets de
caisse d'epargne qu'est ce que c'est
d'autre que de l'optique de
l'optimisation fiscale
le principe est le même on était mise
puisqu'à une optimisation que de se dire
je vais être là je vais aller écrire mon
bateau 201 être et le mettre à l'île de
man pour ne pas payer de la tva est
finalement fraude et de la télé donc
quelque part il ya alors après c'est
plus morale que les gars là normalement
oralement est-ce que de tous les gens
qui se sont fait dénoncé parce que c'est
un peu de la balance des noms dans
l'essai après après vous avez aimé
balances ton port vous allez adorer
balance tourner évadé fiscal c'est
exactement ça donc on est dans une une
époque est un peu
un peu sale je trouve c'est en balance
des noms sans savoir les gens s'en
repaissent heures tous les matins quand
on sort un cinéaste mais on peut être
trop d'impôts offre mais les intéressés
logique mais il ya quand même il ya
quand même moche et pas quand même un
fossé qui se creuse entre les très
riches et les autres et puis ça va être
ça se raser et puis il ya en même temps
une forme de cynisme se dessiner mes
enchaînements
voilà je ne dis pas qu'il faut qu'il
faut s'évanouir et grimper le long des
murs face à tout cela il ya évidemment
des choses à faire pour essayer de 2,2
de combler plus ou moins ce fossé mais
là c'est vrai que cette forme de cynisme
qui consiste à dire toute façon j'ai le
droit et puis en clair je vois là je
fais quand je veux et je vous aime bon
ben c'est un peu cela le ton qu'il a
utilisée y compris par certains élus jeu
je voyais sur public sénat un sénateur
ancien ministre qui tenait à peu près ce
genre de propos que tu un peu un peu
choquant 10 ans gagne car même après que
l'europe fasse son boulot et que
l'europe accouche d'une uniformisation
augis cannes c'est ce sera volontarisme
il ya des réticences de pays parce que
je sais qu'il ya pas d'intérêt commandes
c'est des intérêts nationaux et les
intérêts nationaux sont pas les mêmes
d'un pays à l'autre en europe c'est ça
le problème
aussi même de l'europe et willow 10 ans
maintenant
ce mec on attend une de time comme le
futur patron de l'europe avec avec un
petit une petite trace numérique ce qui
est quand même très très drôle
alors on va parler de droit du conseil
d'état
c'est puisque le conseiller d'état vous
savez c'était ça s'est passé à ploërmel
cédant bretagne où il y avait une statue
de jean-paul ii surmonté du dic droits
et le conseil d'état où nous la laïcité
a demandé ordonné le retrait de cette
croix alors on peut les aborder de
manière juridique face à débattre la
laïcité
enfin sur la laïcité on peut l'aborder
de manière juridique aux deux manières
vous n'aurez que vos morale alors
juridiquement d'abord peut-être c'est
moi qui vous avez peut-être pas eu le
temps de regarder l'arrêt mais
juridiquement une solution attendue
puisque la loi de 1905 est très clair
sur ce terrain elle dit qu'il est
interdit d'apposer des signes religieux
donc sur l'espace public donc là il y
avait effectivement une croix devant
plus de 7 m'étais mis nous on ne fait
pas s'y tromper qui en a mais la croix
est assez petit
lacroix surplomb une croix quand même et
donc le évidemment la loi de 1905
s'appliquer il y à a mis d'accord et
donc là l'interdiction était était
attendu donc la question ne se pose plus
tôt sur le terrain sur finalement
l'opportunité de modifier ou pas la loi
de 1905 sur sur ce point là où j'ai un
problème de logique c'est que pas de
problème pour supprimer effectivement la
croix dès lors qu'elle est sur un
endroit public mais dans ce cas faut
supprimer de l'ensemble du monument
parce que c'est un tout foran les gens
parlent d'eux si oui non mais on peut
considérer jean paul ii est un chef
d'état ce qu'il était mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'il est frespech avec une
croix au dessus non non évidemment la
wii mais jean baptiste jean baptiste a
raison en disant que la loi de 1905
interdit à partir du moment où elles
entrent en vigueur d'apposer des croix
leurs souches dans l'est sur les
sépultures
il ya une affaire aussi sur un relative
à l'implantation d'une croix sur le
portail d'un cimetière la commune avait
remis cette croix alors qu'elles en
avaient été enlevés et le lait les
opposants ont été déboutés devant le
juge administratif qui a dit mais il y
avait une croix avant 1905 donc le maire
et la culture l'art placer là où elle
était et puis sur les édifices religieux
évidemment ou historiques
mais là on peut considérer que cette
statue sans la croix est un hommage à un
personnage historique et un chef d'état
et voilà que va-t-on faire des calvaires
alors qu'ils allaient calvaire font
partie des édifices du culte sont
rattachés il est difficile et que donc
donc ça c'est absolument vous n'allez
pas nous les rasets donc la même que les
médecins dans les cimetières france est
exactement la confiance votre bonté ou
des honneurs c'est la loi de 1905 n'est
pas une loin
n'est pas une loi aussi stricte que vous
le pensez ce une loi d'apaisement avant
tout et les gens qui s'en servent à tire
larigot en ce moment sont quand même
pour moi c'est les idiots utiles de
l'islamisme célébrer non non mais où on
est on est vraiment à la rue de zlatic
et il ya déjà des faces de la question
des racines chrétiennes dans le monde la
bretagne puis c'est même pas une
question c'est une réalité
c'est une réalité partiel c'est ça qui
est gênant parlons aussi des racines que
notre civilisation plongera dans la
philosophie des lumières d'une révision
siècle dans la civilisation celte que
sais-je encore enfin les racines fait
thierry la république il ya quelques
années quand même plus des églises et
cathédrales que de mosquées en france
mais quand on en vient à nier les
racines chrétiennes de la france âgés de
5 et personne ne vient que si vous venez
dire on s'est dit ce qu il n y ait pas
eu lieu pour les crèches faire une
crèche sur une place publique pourquoi
pas dans une mairie n'ont pas les
écoliers des prières de rue est ce que
le cul cul mais je suis allé me sayyed
est dommage c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
de salles de plus ce sont les mêmes élus
qui interdisent la construction de
mosquées ou la location de salles de
prière et qui sont critiques vis-à-vis
des prières de rue
s'il ya des prières de rue c'est qui a
pas cette place pour l'exercice du brut
re plonger tout laïque là ce serait non
non non non non c'est pas ça
la laïcité c'est aussi la liberté pour
chacun de pratiquer la religion de son
choix de son choix ou de n'en pratiquer
au milieu de ces caisses est ouvert
c'est pas faire moi laissons cette croix
là où elle est
de toute façon au maire le maire a
refusé et 10 et annoncé qu'il ne
retirerait pas ses mots donnent
l'exemple
l'élu qui respecte les décisions de
justice soit rendue au nom du peuple
tout à l'heure on avait trois cent
quatorze enseignants qui ceux qui se
moquent bien ça fait 315 avec le maire
[Rires]
et c'est sur ce film cold blooded
rebelles nous quitter avec regret mais
on se retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paf
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
[Musique]